in a perfect world movie lovers pockets
would always be lined with enough cash
to buy tickets to every single film that
ever screened in theaters
unfortunately we live in the decidedly
flawed reality that makes scene and
appreciating every movie pretty much
impossible
year after year a ton of incredible
films are released only to end up going
largely unnoticed and 2018 is no
different
here are some of the most
underappreciated movies you've already
missed in 2018
i kill giants adapted from writer joe
kelly and artist j
m kim nimuro's graphic novel i kill
giants danish director
anders walters adaptation stars madison
wolf as the plucky barbara thorson
barbara is an oddball outsider with a
bunny ear cap a head in the clouds and a
norse warhammer in her bag
you see barbara fancies herself a killer
of giants and is convinced that a horde
of them are coming to earth
and she's the only one who can vanquish
them blending together an impactful
coming-of-age tale themes of grief and
denial
solid cgi and captivating performances
from wolf and supporting actors imogen
poots zoe saldana and sydney wade
i kill giants is a magnificent monster
movie that's monstrously moving
critics have applauded it as never less
than engrossing and you'll agree
thoroughbreds murder is on the menu and
writer director corey finley's
thoroughbreds a black comedy thriller
that centers around childhood friends
lily
played by anya taylor joy and amanda
played by olivia cook who reunite to
cook up a devious plan
even though both are born and raised in
the suburbs lily's years at boarding
school and an illustrious internship
have turned her into a prim and proper
goody two-shoes
whereas amanda's unidentified mental
disorder has turned her into an
emotionless outcast with a smart mouth
and stinging wit
opposites attract in this case and the
two end up fueling the worst in one
another
as they bond over a shared contempt they
both hate lilly's tyrannical stepfather
mark played by paul sparks
and resolved to bring him to a grisly
end lily and amanda's scheming leads
them to recruit drug dealer tim
played by the dearly departed anton
yelchin whom the girls manipulate into
becoming their personal hitman the
murder mission takes more than a few
unexpected turns arriving at an end you
likely won't see coming
rarely do first-time creatives get their
debut as right as finley did with
thoroughbreds a darkly alluring film
most everyone agrees that thoroughbreds
has the potential to be a classic and
despite the film's lack of big budget
promotion and pre-release hype it'll be
revisited by audiences for years
the endless the endless snagged a bunch
of relentlessly positive reviews after
it opened
in a limited run on april 6 but was
buried by its box office competition
john krasinski's a quiet place which
debuted to 50 million dollars that same
weekend
the endless is a perception twisting
thriller that takes one terrifying
moment
brothers justin and aaron receiving a
cryptic video from members of a ufo
death cult they were once a part of
and springboards into the insane rather
than burning the tape and getting on
with their lives
justin and aaron decide to head back to
the exact place they narrowly escaped a
decade earlier in hopes of finally
getting closure
as incomprehensible horror starts
surrounding the camp justin and aaron
are forced to reconsider if the cult was
actually preaching the truth
a slow-burning horror that shocks in its
second half but frightens the whole way
through
the endless is an underappreciated movie
you'll wish you had paid more attention
to before learning about it right now
lean on pete director andrew high's lean
on pete perfectly adapts willy vlotton's
touching novel and spreads it
beautifully across the silver screen for
the world to see
it's a film festival darling and a
favorite among critics but has gone
seriously underappreciated by casual
moviegoers
lenon pete follows burgeoning young star
charlie plummer as charlie
a 15 year old boy who moves to rural
portland with his father ray played by
travis fimmel
as his father spirals further into
himself charlie discovers companionship
and camaraderie at a racetrack where he
becomes the new attendant to a
weathering racehorse named leon pete
while there he also befriends the
horse's owner del montgomery and his
jockey bonnie
played respectively by steve buscemi and
chloe seveney but don't let the premise
fool you
lenon pete is no lighthearted movie
about a young boy and the love he feels
for an aging horse in his new pals
as critics have proclaimed the film is a
haunting tale of survival a
heartbreaking look at a marginalized
america that's likely to leave you in
tatters
goldstone take everything you've learned
about australia from crocodile dundee
internet jokes about riding kangaroos to
school and then throw a shrimp on the
barbie restaurant chain outback
steakhouse and toss it in the bin
goldstone from multi-talented writer
director composer cinematographer ivan
sin
presents the australian outback in an
intimate thrilling new way
set in the titular town of goldstone the
movie follows indigenous detective jay
swann
played by aaron pederson as he journeys
up to the tiny mining outpost
he's there to aid josh a young policeman
played by alex russell and goldstone's
mayor played by jackie weaver to
investigate the disappearance of a
chinese tourist
an already complex case turns tense
because of jay's identity as both
an aborigine and as a law enforcement
officer his presence in town ruffles the
feathers of both the racists of
goldstone
and the town's aboriginal residents when
jay discovers that josh and the mayor
may not be as innocent as they'd like
others to believe
the gripping noir narrative takes yet
another unexpected turn
released a high praise but underwhelming
box office in australia in 2016
goldstone made its theatrical debut in
the united states in march of 2018
where it performed much the same the raw
sunblasted pick didn't get as much
attention as it deserved
[Music]
gemini the neo-noir thriller gemini
lives up to the split personality
implication of its title
as you're never really sure of the true
intentions of its leading lady the lady
in question is lola kirk as jill lebeau
the assistant to hollywood it girl
heather anderson played by zoe kravitz
one evening jill discovers heather's
lifeless body the result of a gunshot
wound slumped in a pool of blood in her
otherwise immaculate multi-million
dollar mansion and she decides to embark
on a mission to solve the mystery of her
former boss's murder meanwhile
jill must also stay a step ahead of the
relentlessly determined detective edward
ahn played by john cho who senses she's
the one who committed the heinous crime
can she or will the skeletons jill has
long kept shoved in her closet finally
break free
am i under arrest not yet written
directed and edited by award-winning
independent filmmaker erin katz
gemini has earned a mostly positive
response with critics they've dubbed the
kaleidoscope film a piece of clean
confident visual storytelling and a
shimmering puzzler that warps into an
unlikely detective story in the cold
weather vein if that description doesn't
entice you to catch this seriously
underappreciated movie what will
bomb city one part pulpy crime story one
part heart grabbing drama bomb city is a
brilliant little film that made a bang
without the general public even noticing
the jameson brooks directed film stars
dave davis as brian a punk music
obsessed teen from amarillo texas
who sticks out like a mohawk thumb in
his conservative town thankfully there
are a few other punks out there who view
brian as a sort of mouthpiece for the
movement
sadly there are an equal number of
bullying jocks who regularly clash with
the punks
tensions bubble below the surface then
explode in a violent altercation that
comes with a fatal consequence
a native of amarillo director brooks
base bomb city on the real-life story of
the town's violent confrontation between
a group of punks and bullies
not only does the film present the
tragedy of the violence in a truthful
and harrowing light
it also serves as a reminder that the
american justice system isn't always
moral
not everyone is as unassuming or as
aggressive as their outward appearance
may suggest
unsane you may think you know director
steven soderbergh
but you've never seen him like this
before the mind behind films like out of
sight
erin brockovich and logan lucky cast
aside the traditional trappings of
filmmaking and embraces b-movie mojo
with unsane a psychological horror
thriller pick shot entirely on an iphone
7 plus
the crown actress claire foy leads the
ambitious film as sawyer valentini a
financial analyst who moved away from
her hometown in an attempt to evade her
longtime stalker david shrine played by
joshua leonard
a confession to her therapist about her
self-destructive thoughts gets sawyer a
one-way ticket into a mental institution
where she's held for 24 hours of
observation there
sawyer is soon forced to confront her
darkest fear while trapped inside the
institution's walls
the only question is is the fear real or
just a product of her paranoia
as disturbing as the experimental unsane
is it didn't drum up as much buzz as
you'd expect
still though it's under appreciated by
the masses it hasn't gone without
critical praise
the new yorker's richard brody calls on
sane one of soderberg's best movies
the very spark of his artistic passion
all the more reason to see it yourself
you were never really here joaquin
phoenix is in top form and you were
never really here
writer director lynn ramsey's film
adaptation of jonathan ames novel of the
same name
phoenix gives a darkly intense
performance as joe a former law
enforcement agent and combat veteran
struggling with post-traumatic stress
disorder
joe lives out his post-fbi days as a
hired gun earning cash to support
himself and his ailing mother played by
judith roberts by locating missing and
trafficked young girls
but he also experiences intense suicidal
fantasies one of which almost becomes
reality before his boss played by john
doman
snaps him back to the surface world and
tasks him with finding 13 year old nina
the daughter of a state senator
though joe is properly equipped for the
violence of the job what he isn't
prepared for is the triple layer twist
in syrian horrors that await him
touted as stark sinewy and slash to the
bone you are never really here
is a masterclass in filmmaking more than
worthy of the type of global adulation
its heavily promoted cinematic
counterparts have received this year
sweet country another blistering drama
out of australia sweet country centers
around hamilton morris as middle-aged
aboriginal farmer sam kelly
who works for a preacher in the northern
territory sam and his family are sent to
assist a cruel ill-tempered war veteran
named harry march
played by ewan leslie in renovating his
cattle yards in alice springs
as the two work together to build the
yards up their relationship quickly
deteriorates coming to a chaotic head
when sam fatally shoots harry in an act
of self-defense
as sam flees across the unforgiving
australian outback to outrun the
relentless sergeant fletcher and his
hunting party
the truth behind the killing comes out
in response the community is left to
ponder whether capturing sam is justice
or just vengeance we suspect most
skipped out on the limited release of
sweet country in favor of the widely
launched a quiet place
which made its massive debut on the same
day and that's a shame
beyond its engrossing visuals and
rhythmic pacing sweet country has
captivated those who did see it with its
powerful and universal story that
lingers long after the credits have
rolled